ring you know when he wanted to like
this and his back was like oh my god and
as I didn't know that if you look bigger
and know that many not only took De La
Hoya's soul but he took mixing in some
ones as well by the way we broke we
shared this podcast and I wanted people
to hear how we talk when the mics are
not on we're talking about Manny
Pacquiao's back and steroids and boxing
hey first my club you'll talk to your
right with a man leader the man meter
with West Chatham up in this [ __ ] is
about to hit red hot and I want to
apologize if it goes even past the red
and we break the man meter because we're
not [ __ ] around
Chatham walks in here I don't know if
he's doing a movie about Special Forces
who are guys who are tan with no hair on
their body but the kid walks in with a
boat collar shirt and jogger pants with
adorable all leather hydrops you know
that well that's haircut fractures and
even break out all the time and jamming
back you use doing move you move your
special salon oh it comes back oh looks
like this is why oh I broke we run
stairs I've seen them like this just
written Wayne McCullough Wayne McCullen
said that he had to tell West twice
after he dropped two dudes and sparring
he goes hey man we're just moving around
but look you punch too hard you gotta
take it back kitchen it's wrong I go I
go hit you strong but hey just longs to
people when they come around I'm gonna
quote a guy side to side Instagram like
what's the picture Nixon Meyer Lopez he
looks like a blast and Maya Lopez the
same thing does we look like we got in
horrible car accidents thanks man
we look like we're recovering horrible
car like that some guy with a poses that
Mario Lopez because wow I'm nursing sob
look like you got a horrible actor that
guy though that you I was really in bed
reading I couldn't sleep and I looked at
that I laughed so hard
Lopez is a good-looking kid but I want
to call about anything you say with with
with the pocket rocket because in Brian
and I both train with Wayne one of my
favorite people but you just show up and
he puts you in a ring somebody he
doesn't tell you level or anything and I
like angels I get nervous yeah cuz I'm
like I didn't come here no so not murder
yes
yeah we like table play around with
John when you put this guy in there and
you don't know the skill level you don't
know whatever you're nervous like and
then you feel like an ass well wait out
loud but Wayne always his rule is that
you have to ask Wayne so so if somebody
came and asked me to spar and he got mad
at that about that because he said they
should always go through me because I
can I'm gonna screen whoever you're
going to get in there boys I'm going to
let you get in there with some guys try
head-on yeah it's really good right
right so he takes it very seriously
because yeah his job well you gotta
watch he didn't know how hard you hit
that somebody wants to go anything in
queues was like you're right like when
you go in there stretch of you're with a
guy you you don't want to go too easy
like Jay and I were time out and shut up
Jay shops in town for the big round bake
down tonight but um my buddy Klopas NFL
you know first round pick our first pick
in the second round freak athlete we
will talk about him he was sparring a
little bit Sparta chick Sparta girls
like um she would go easy he took
another girl and I was right he's on
wobbly Street of my Junius palm sock bro
and his jaws all [ __ ] up he's seen
stars you gonna hate me Fratellis doing
yes I just didn't know man I have my
habit of me it was over a woman she came
in and just she's trying to keep
training really working to she's
fighting an amateur but she I stepped
aside she's but this is it left hand I
thought I was gonna [ __ ] die right I
was like oh that's bad now we'll keep
going anywhere I never works out when
you spar girls like when I was at high
altitude Osbourne and this guy his wife
she was known for going hard and there
just was a lot of people and just the
rotation work um I know I need his sweat
all right and we're going and she's
going so hard like getting wiped on side
like if you touch Bend we will give you
a million because if you just touch it
she's going so hard right like I don't
know what to do I didn't want to get
hurt she's going go on I look around no
one's watching like I got to do
something here to calm it down it goes
right to the liver you okay I'm like oh
[ __ ] I think probably all right I'm
gonna try like gee you ran into that one
you know that's kind of legit had a girl
girl you know I would imagine got your
size when you sparred guys I was runner
that's right [ __ ] is faster you [ __ ]
missed a [ __ ] done with women matter
- that's right woman
don't go pro protest a winner feminist
you were giving her you were giving away
you get the guy protest somewhere else
[ __ ] nothing is not up in here don't
ever bring that [ __ ] into my champion
hate your kids you go to another gym
place your Lululemon lovin [ __ ] ourself
go to another gym we just lost every
female is everybody hit a liver shot
there's a nasty purple belt glasses the
girl she's like half my size I always
avoid her because I might dude she
chokes me out I know she keep it so
clear let's definitely she's let your
guard down the way you wanna be a guy
dominated really like when Michelle
Waterson used to train with us
I like shootin dimepiece you know shower
gel she may now kid gorgeous she's
worthy spandex you know and you like
manner alter right now I'm not trying to
[ __ ] get this raging boner yeah you know
you like you gonna like mama sit this
round
yeah and so had some beautiful women
that would come in sometimes you'd have
some some some beautiful well they look
like powerful men but but like here he
would have some of these gorgeous women
in there and they'd just be like
Brazilian and they'd be like these
American girls were kind of there to
roll but also kind of there to meet a
guy maybe land you know miel pervert oh
if you need a guy's what role did
intently I'd be happy to roar shelf girl
North salad who I start here oh what's
this I'm gonna turtle you're back I'm on
your back now get out guess I'll try to
pass your guard or will I or well I I'll
just apply pressure
your abs are collared yo choked ever
done the color dick Joe color insert
didn't hey hey what does too much I
flats equal hell brother I'm glad you're
finally on man why no man I'm really
glad to be one of the busiest guys in
the business to like you were in it and
I don't know you don't have to give the
name of the movie I'm gonna try and talk
about homeboy was like and you don't
tell me [ __ ] because we never stops we
worked out all the time right
he'll go missing for six weeks he comes
back on my [ __ ] day did I was special
to be sent Murray we're doing all right
how was that movie and what it's what
it's like slides great man I was a don't
call him slide okay guys oh is that
really Jay glass right yeah yeah okay
great it's on the stone break that's why
oh yeah you wait what I call you know
sit this one out though guys you have
never worked in semester-long and Haley
you're good friends though you never
just know what he says you know at first
I was so worried because when I first
met him and he go into hate fly West
Westland shook my hand looked at me had
this just disappointed look it was the
first time we met and everything kind of
look you know like he was disappointed I
don't know who your hero to like oh my
god let us say we're close same it's
like special own was the man dude I love
so as the first rocky the first Rambo
with him I forget it for Jam first blood
overall nothing better than this coke
lockup you mean lock and I know you
Myrna Nighthawks would record Howard oh
yeah it's doing it I'm glad you guys
know this is my generation he did
something so hero to you you get the gig
I get this your first time meeting him
first time so we can Li meet you know me
and sly working together so I'm so
excited you know like you know you go
over quite conversations in your head of
how it's going to go and so I met him
and then I was like [ __ ] and I
he discipline side rocky thinks in a
[ __ ] like I kind of had that view yes
and then you're pretty was he kind of
cold-blooded or it was kind of cold he
was kind of like he just kind of seemed
disappointed but later I found out this
week for yes that it works and then you
know the guy that got him playing was
like you know it's meticulously dressed
and everything so I don't know you know
kind of would throw him off but as we
started working in any fan I was in
military he does a lot of stuff for the
military and everything and so that kind
of connected us and then he was the
greatest really and then he kind of
opened up and I think in the beginning
what it wasn't a meeting do with me you
know we always make it about I think he
had a lot on his mind because
you know you had a tremendous workload
in this and he was he pretty much like
he choreographed our whole fight like
when we went into the thing and so he
dad yeah a lot of his mind I think he
was just thinking about things and I was
like dammit rocky doesn't like me man
yeah and then uh but then as sooner we
started working together they really
opened up and what was great about him
and I think you guys should have him on
the show he's a big fight fan and he'd
like to get yeah you guys have to get
him blue slime he's got a great he's
funny [ __ ] but what's great about it is
he's open about talking about his movies
like we're talking about his past
oh well whereas some of the people have
looked up to that guy toward before and
I'm like hey man let's start trying to
talk about the films and they don't want
it they don't know but he you know he's
open he'll take time and so I went
through the whole filmography in between
spaceman as soon as I it's really like
lettuce one in Sun a lot of you remember
that time in over-the-top when was this
or like like yeah and over the top he
called his son son I think
come on son yeah yeah really weird
Sanjay come son I love you son with a
man what makes him so special west like
he's such a foursome made you know
anything out do you know how old he is
he's not heavenly I think you've seen
his body there's his picture he's highly
intelligent man he doesn't know why
super intelligence worked out again soon
it dude it's his work and one thing that
that really struck me from him is
because he is 70 but the age disappears
cuz he looks he's built like a brick
[ __ ] yeah I mean he looks good for
a 27 year old like he's Jack he's a
walking advertisement for testosterone
and human growth for today's doing it
right
ah look at me what you desire here
gorgeous wife never stops working never
never never stops working right kids are
dying he's the American dream yeah but
you and I were Thomas when we were
working out I was like man you see
Sylvester well it's not an accident it's
not like you like whoops no no
successful crash you're saying it just
his workout with that workout his
daughters are also really well-adjusted
in cool people right what I've read and
what I you know and he's he's a guy's
guy you know I mean it has that kind of
sense humor but I'm sure you've had this
experience we've what you get to work
with somebody you really looked up to
and you realize that at this point that
just kind of
phone it in they don't yeah they don't
really pay attention what's going on
Karen that is not so long and so what I
would really struck me was working with
him was how present and aware and
hardworking and paid attention he was
deep into the script he was deep he
cared about every aspect he'd care
deeply about he did when we did our
fight stuff he did everything himself
talking about 1:07 choreographed the
look at we had fought really yeah he did
everything himself and so I would you
know I saw this like man this guy is
another level of concentration
intelligence and work ethic his movie
fighting I assume he has to be one the
best in the business because and Brian
taught me this when we were shooting our
TV show fine kid 3d when we would fake
fight with a fake fight scenes if I
didn't you know I'm not used to it worse
but now I'm too out high and tight I'm
high yeah
you know I've been boxing too long right
right and finds a good dude it looks
terrible
okay Mike and wise like you're covering
your face with your hands when you punch
your it's too like you it's too good you
have to open up yeah I have the same
problem I had exactly problem and that's
in that in and I learned he's actually
very patient a great teacher in terms of
movie fighting and I remember doing the
scene I'm like oh you know it says rocky
and I and I you know it's like I've been
training a box I'm gonna show him you
know good form and I was tight and
moving right and and he immediately
first he changed the fight choreography
and he said you know let's let's do this
let's do that where's the camera at you
know I mean just kind of like really
figured out how to do it but then he
said to me he's like it's not tight you
know movies he's like you come back here
to where you're touching a floor and
you're swinging across and when I first
did it it felt really a lien to me it
was like a whole different let it hang
and then you know Telegraph the punches
and stomach and then we wouldn't watch
playback on the monitor and I was like
holy [ __ ] looks like he completely
trained me how to do that movie type
might be fine and there's no completely
different animal really different and
the thing is like when people talk about
Stallone like the the reason Rocky's
Rocky is because of Stallone you know if
you think about boxing movies since then
he wrote that movie yeah
he wrote there remember that look first
of all first of all he not only write
the movie they offered him money for the
script and Robert De Niro was going to
play that role what yes he said no I
know he said no and he and he said I'm
in a play I'm in starring as myself and
John Albertson time who was a director
of rocky was a young new director - and
you know they just went yeah what a game
changing move yeah I'm all the work
that's one of the great autumn a driver
he was doing that rocky the movie Rocky
in 1975 I think was 75 and was
responsible for for the they allowed to
say was responsible for the workouts add
for the exercise phenomenon that took
America people started running drinking
eggs that's creating all kinds of [ __ ]
that would be such a big deal and think
about all the great boxes to ever be
born and raised in Philadelphia so
that's just so lonely how about that
she's got so Wester Stallone has been
fired by Bill burr goober when he was
getting booed and Philadelphia for me is
like you racist [ __ ] you racist
[ __ ] they'd be got you got Joe
Frazier what a great boxers you got to
statue to a guy's not even a real boxer
I hope you get carjacked by a bunch of
black guys me away half rapper to show
you [ __ ] I hope they come in your
face
what do they let them know over they
believed they were just in a mood to
boot everybody I think was an Opie and
Anthony show and they were in the mood
to boot everybody that came up and over
was iron my iron my shirt for this [ __ ]
you [ __ ] out it was the beginning of
Bill burrs ascension nobody knew bill
and when he did that we were all
watching that on YouTube you can bring
it up it's bad quality but it's so fun
during that up Jim you know you know
what Stallone sparred Joe Frazier for
real like that day back in the day when
you say for real yeah Frazier walk
around with moved around with him yeah
yeah I mean but he broke his eye in okay
I mean he's escaped a little eight
stitches yet go they were doing rock III
in so long wanted Hagan he wanted Victor
keep going and so they're getting ready
to do rock III and sly wanted to up the
like nobody had a real fighter at that
time and the kne and it was his idea
he's like look I want to bring the
realism of Rocky to another level maybe
we get so Frazier came out
and they were he was going to play
clubber lang oh yeah
and he said let's get in the ring and
move around a little bit and in a couple
rounds and we'll video and we'll see how
it looks and if it's a good chemistry
so they started they start so they
started moving around it's like dude
Frasier doesn't know how to no no he's
like actually like yeah there's a
knowing that you're Asian anything
everyone whether it's of all time and
everybody everybody that fights Joe
Frazier is never the same after ever and
rocky gets in the ring with him and do
it he said that he got hit with a left
hook it split his eye wide-open age
there's a picture of it he has on
Instagram eight stitches all the way
down Wow
yeah and he said you know what let's
bring this yeah yeah you know how he
found the tributing you know like that
mr. t yeah he would learn that answer he
won the toughest bouncer yeah he's a
music down sir and he's at the front
door yeah bouncing it well he won no he
actually won a big competition when he
was about yeah yeah yeah yeah that would
made miss yeah yeah he had no acting
experience now anything I wanna bounce
like ups bouncer never yeah no yeah they
had this big ups now heard the doubles
down - yeah here's a trivia question
what boxer in rocky in the first rocky
was - that's a strong sparring partner
Frank Stallone no he's a boxer a real
boxer who did they have in the ring in
Rocky
yeah Lonsdale Rocky yeah in rasgueado
no no boom-boom antenna no not Mancini
it's pretty wild
so so there's a scene where Rocky is
sparring with oh um it's a black guy
no [ __ ] Roberto dude I'm oh really
what yeah it's really cool and I watched
it I was like that guy's a guy you know
he kept touching his belt you know he
touched you and come back out pennsville
I was like that's [ __ ] inverted rent
you know his brother that his brothers
in in the movie fighting his brother in
movie - yeah let me let's see let me see
real boroughs Philadelphia now I want to
watch yeah do you like I'll just put
this back for a while just
bill burns gets punished I think my
lover I cook up my brain talking about
nothing right now I'm just walking
around again just got a cheeseburger out
all your peoples know us compromise
losers I hope y'all [ __ ] dive and I
hope the [ __ ] he knows all you go
away into - just lick my [ __ ] redness
off you can line up your Harold
Carmichael [ __ ] jerking of one at a
time to get all don't like it
[ __ ] analogies or gel people have gotten
an acid if you ever get talking about
anything work what do you only talk
about pockets and talk about hard to do
something you're all going to [ __ ]
die you [ __ ] cancer which is
fantastic is on your [ __ ] heads in
shape in any way nobody is going to know
get fired from I work too late so that I
didn't notice that you have [ __ ] bone
marrow cancer
the only things going to give it away is
being laughing at you with a cosmic
background [ __ ] cell phone
did everyone it is living he's like I'm
doing all my time [ __ ] ass Ben
Franklin Bridge one rich habit [ __ ] Pig
[Laughter]
spending on your club happens involved
cancer all of you 11 minutes west
haha somebody takes a [ __ ] beer sign
it just slapped you on the passenger's
[ __ ] Vestas [ __ ] shoulder and you're
awesome man fits well 12 minutes that's
[ __ ] legendary dude if you want I can
watch somebody die why did you hear the
part where he got a statue to a boxer
met a real boxer yeah Joe Frazier you
racist [ __ ] won't put a statue up for a
black guy but a guy who pretends to be a
boxer in a movie a [ __ ] loser does so
brilliant round the spot he dangles
related wealth Pittsburgh would provoke
that was birthday they were booing
Dahmer era the legs whatever bombers
from Philly they were just in a mood to
be [ __ ] Billy is an acrylic bounce
and their drink indels get ya and third
snowballs oh yeah if they're drinking
they're not in the mood to [ __ ] it out
there they'll punch in the face be
better than wild rest our first time
yeah not this last time you said because
I want to get out of here I was like I
know it's a growth of the reasons I just
say well we did a too long the show they
were boozing they were drinking a lot
yeah and we do fan questions and you get
a riot you can see like raucous dick oh
my god well you got a question [ __ ] you
all right all right you know what how's
Rhonda's [ __ ] saying yeah I bro I don't
do is that a question you can hear it
start to rumble every room and he starts
getting mad and all the guy that's just
could ask yeah Brian's legs up you did I
hear you [ __ ] Jew I'm a Jewish
thought about what are you talking about
you yeah that's where I go yeah they're
turning anti somatically Abu is really
lucky they'll go yeah
and what I feel great though yeah I mean
you know if we went back to this
restaurant [ __ ] though there's a bunch
of big names in that movie right
you say the movie yeah it's uh it's
called Hades escape plan because there's
a skater game before right Hades there
was a plane before
it wasn't the word in Greek mythology it
was their skate play movie but yes or
well that was with Arnold in Spanish and
Arnold and I seen that right was it
break out or break when he a plan
mixtape is a sequel to the sequel yet
and who else is in this side Dave
Bautista is in it he stuff killed it man
yeah he's crushed which is Dave Davidson
he's the WWE guy big wwk he's in
guarding the galaxy's lure resident he's
like I know he's the right guy reggae
he's I think I think Batista he's like
the rock but it's rock he's like the
rock at the rock got in the face of
million times with a shovel yeah he's
good luck yeah he's like he's like he's
like if they're booking a movie like can
rock they're like no I called the T
stone well yo good thing about patita
and snow in this movie in general is
like I've worked with people that are
make a living off being tough guys but
fate like movie tough guys like Stallone
is legit tough he does everything and so
is batiste I think Jesus guys Brownlow
well why do you think that Stallone one
of the exciting part of a secret of
success he stayed in his Lane I get away
in other words he's done he seems to
only do action movies and has always had
an appetite for action movies and he's
never wanted to do the other things that
older men end up doing right Robinson
head yeah yeah he never does not he
doesn't he close she two robbers no so
as a muffaletta miked up in a New York
restaurant he only dates black woman
Jack Robertson L threaten the black
lady's theater and they're at a do you
know they're drinking something and
they're you know arguing yes I would
have to make these shitty [ __ ] movies
I'm doing now if you didn't spend all my
goddamn money I'll have to play a
grandpa every goddamn cruder he doesn't
yeah but he he actually talked about
that cuz that because I said cuz he did
you see Kaplan I love da plan he was so
good in Kaplan was such a great movie
and I said you know did you ever think
about moving
more dramatic when you're doing that and
he says no he says you know I I felt
early on that I wanted to be a
specialist in something I wanted to be
something that nobody could be better at
me am and so I focused on an action
career and what's interesting is you
think about it think of the the still
the drawing power that Stallone has for
being a specialist like everything like
a lot of those guys that were legends
they can't get movies made now yeah I
don't actually go see a movie yeah I'm
talking about dramatic actors are these
like let they have Oscars and everything
right they have a hard time game movies
made because she's all by action moves
yeah save your age you got to play you
know yeah Jeff Bridges is done a good
job but for the most part you're right
it's but but he did know he did a
Copland which is an incredible movie oh
yeah and he was he held his own with
Harvey Keitel Robert De Niro like you
know he knew it was so long right yeah
but he also liked kids movies think
about now action movies are still but
they've always been the big smooth
always always the biggest moneymakers
yes always always always
but even if his you know Expendables 19
here does decent but then in China in
overseas they say he [ __ ] killed it
man yeah heals it yeah at 70 I just like
anybody who rages against the the sort
of the night you know yeah anybody gonna
set the Machine there but now that is
that's just an expression of a an
expression that's a Shakespeare
experiment raging against and raging
against like the fact that you're going
to die someday like he will not he's is
ha 90 70 years old yes hungry is 7 years
old and I'm sorry but you can see it on
his body I can say whatever you want
about him takings of the Danielle poem
work that's the pressure of still always
not exercising I always stand like in
shape but the thing that level in what's
the point it looks different the lesson
be is that like for some older guys like
dude give it up night with him I don't
feel like that I'm like doing you're
killing it yeah I do believe going that
yeah look at that look I mean we came
right here he's got tasks that's recent
that's recent that's what he's like
yeah you can't argue with that and he's
extremely disciplined
yeah and that I mean look I'm be
soldering 270 is that a fake those are
fake tattoos no those are real you got
those I mean you gotta love a guy whose
is not giving
no stuttering Arnold he trains it yet
honor went politics he went he does look
better on he trains that J glaze is dren
oh I'm breakable yeah unbreakable chains
over there look at that [ __ ] do it
jack yeah that's impressive everything
you see in this movie he did it the
movie that to look at when he's younger
look at that got that picture right
there yep first it's not like a lot of
people like give it and like let it go
man but with him my keep [ __ ] doing it
yeah as Greg there's a lot of guys I see
him like come on man Mickey Mickey
Rourke
man yeah well Mickey works a little bit
different because he really tore his
face up to he got cheek implants he got
fake lips he he's a product of real
abuse he was really abused by his
father's so time I thought a father is
legitimate yeah but he was also just
he's very self-destructive I love the
other recent fight I saw him so tagging
on his Instagram posts he's hitting that
he's that wild card he's hitting the
double end bag and he's holding his
chihuahua in his other hand he's awesome
make it work was my favorite actor me
too I think did UFC boy fly did I see
more flies seen everything he's
everybody gathered a little weighed into
his face you know he wasn't great in
Ironman look at him there he had a fight
he had a fight promoter openly that way
but I think he's one of the most gift
naturally gifted actors Wow most people
say ever right like he's top for me as
an actor for me I think he broke my
heart every time you know every time
they look what he broke my heart an Iron
Man 3 like that was when he was just so
beautiful now he just destroyed himself
well now now he looks you know I'm not
and I appreciate him I respected me
looks like a monster yeah yeah really
tell you straight up monster yeah he
just keeps that's that's that's
self-hatred that's he's so professional
like he just he's wrestled with terrible
women deal with it onto though it's like
you start touching your face next thing
you know it's like whoa what the [ __ ]
kind of sad cuz you look at that and
you're like it'll it'll never look like
to Mickey Rourke that we no no no well
my son's gonna grow up and look at him
like holy [ __ ]
he's not raising well he's trying to
he's doing it's that weird thing where
he's trying to stop from dying or
stop from being old more like you know
he dresses yeah like he was tights and
[ __ ] scarves in the middle like Wicca
but he still met and everything is good
and everything is magnet wrestler yo my
oh my god I mean angel wrestler was
breaking I get mad when I see these
pictures yes I he was such he was my he
was my favorite right my favorite he
broke my heart
like Mickey like so Johnny Depp has
never broken my heart like I've seen him
in movies and he's really cool but
didn't break my heart
pilots week early yeah he's great but he
doesn't break my heart where's and I
think that's one of the reason his
movies don't make money and that's one
of the reason that back tribute that's
the only movie but for the most part
Johnny Depp Forbes magazine said the
only the guy who will give you the least
amount return on your money is Johnny
Depp of all the movie stars it's really
okay I think you'd get two dollars out
of every hundred you spend and and Tim
Burton bill Tim Burton stuff yeah he
made money there but for the most part
all the movies in between never made
money and and I think it's because I
think it's because he didn't as cool as
he is he forgot to be vulnerable
yeah and Mickey Rourke was so vulnerable
good and as men we would go when you're
young man really is that macho yeah you
go I guess it's okay to cry
yeah I feel I would did you see [ __ ]
sorry to change the sides but on the
same topic sort of do you see Jimmy
Kimmel talk about Don Rickles and then
his son no his you see ya and I'm Don
Rickles ii III he retired here to Howard
Stern talk about it no I listen Howard
Stern every morning and Howard was
saying that he's very close with Jimmy
Kimmel and he said he sent all his
closest family and friends an email it
was like Williams been born don't worry
all good seven pounds eight ounces
everything's great we'll send pictures
when we can they said three hours later
he goes sorry to bring the bad news I
spoke too soon there's a heart condition
yes one for open-heart surgery please
pray for William yeah it's like wow yeah
yeah so it's a little baby had some sort
of heart defect I like to open-heart
surgery
imagine the level that technologies out
where they can go to baby's heart was
the size of a [ __ ] almond fix its own
back up thank God in Western medicine
and then Jimmy post a picture of him
holding them down it's a brilliant
picture it's heartbreaking yeah member
of my heart I'll actually
one of the hardest things I think about
having kids is the amount of how
vulnerable you feel like it magnifying
it by ten times I came even when I hear
stories like that I can I can barely
hear stories about what other kids or
something to have bad happen to kids
when Justin rent I want that anything oh
my god just and run posted a firefighter
on his back this terrified child after a
violent car accident was in the
stretcher and terrified and the
firefighters lying down and showing
happy feet on his phone to this little
kid and he was all sweating from saving
and I start crying you know you know
kids I can't take his stuff I can't
watch with speaking of Mickey Rourke can
you I think it's the crossing guard is
Mickey Rourke seen the Mickey work scene
in the crossing guard I don't need open
a crossing guard was he that was on pen
movie yet something directed it so even
there for two minutes
steals the movie yeah he's now I want it
I want I mean we don't to do this
exercise now but I want to show you
something you watch this scene yeah and
I'm pretty sure it's the crossing guard
he's in there for two minutes chomp
Indra it was back when he's down and out
I'll get it to move Shawn pink I'm job
he's in there steals the movie it's one
of the most powerful scenes it's that
one top one the pledge is pledge and you
go but watch the scene man this is
Mickey Rourke right here that is great
as it turns out now he could get a job
at this point and his chompin like I
need to be getting back during his wild
you all the nice drugs and everything so
they bring camp in gave me if he has one
seen James olsat I was a subjective and
most actors like it would have a jolly
Gary black we don't know leaves
detective just like to talk to you about
your daughter
what daughter you did have a daughter
that went missing three years ago didn't
you you come here to tell me that
something happened to her I know if you
find her dead ISM no no sir we're still
trying to find her anything you might
tell me about her she described her she
must be must be different now
see the so pretty spiritual back
community that message
well I we just used to like hold each
other
Oh was lipstick ever and you is not good
girl you know I just
Jim I'm a [ __ ] on yes so I look
here's something interesting and you're
gonna do it now but I want you to posit
on your listeners like this right now
but or not so the we get on the show you
this one Park is going to go back so
well there's only nice I consider yeah
let's watch the rest of it and then I'm
going to tell you something this is my
baby okay what did they cut it out the
same but in if you watch the movie he
looks at his hands and he says I just I
just want to hold her I just want to so
Sean Penn directed this movie
interesting fact go back and watch
Mystic River there's a scene with Sean
Penn who's talking about his daughter
yeah boy he's saying yeah he looks at
his hands because I just I just want to
hold her you know what he said he is
yeah we look at it all the time he loves
Allah Sean Penn look it up to make your
work don't kid yeah don't I don't do it
our time but if you YouTube this and
watch this and then you go to mr.
Thurber and you watch it you could say
Dave honestly he does a good life
example well here's what doesn't
surprise me so so they always say that
De Niro looked up to Robert Duvall right
but when I watched Sean Penn Sean Penn
grew up in LA right but I happen to know
that Sean Penn when I would watch
because my favorite actors of course my
generation I loved Sean Penn but chompin
was too close to my age Robert De Niro
and especially Mickey Rourke
they kind of took everybody by storm if
you listen to Sean Penn Sean Penn became
New York Sean Penn sounds a lot of times
like his brothers he learned of course
he's not he's familiar he's from an alum
Malibu even more yeah but Sean Penn's
original that was that was the template
for what masculinity was for Sean Penn
his dad was a great writer I believe me
oh yeah yeah he said to be the writer
actor Sean Penn likes the old Devils
liquid oh he's got he's got his team
that already likes you I want a ring I'm
so fat now I don't know examples talking
so I meant only about five years old
might want to take a look at I know but
little board exam you can see what an
influence those guys everybody had
heroes everybody everybody has their
heroes your heroes had people they were
emulating it's how we do things we we
download we download I love me some
champagne
but Pitt you kind of went through you
know he had kind of had that Street New
Yorker kind of grit to her eye dude
you're from Malibu he grew up with Rob
Lowe and he hated people Malibu he
wanted to be wrong I love Rob laughs
nothin I guess come back hilarious he's
funny she's a little bit is humor yeah
where is something didn't actually it's
great as he is I wish shop not Haley
would embrace the funny I wish you would
kind of be a little bit defecating
self-deprecating it he takes a
Thursday's that well thing about his
last big thing was the Rolling Stones
article with El Chapo oh yeah took some
he travel got busted yeah that's
literally I was trying to floss right
and then also was a big fan of Sean Penn
and then all that stuff I tell you I god
Madonna said that was her true love
yes she said that yeah dude you I was
listening to uh Brad Pitt you know you
got a divorce from Angelina Jolie and
he's kept like you know it's rare
celebrities talk about you like this
he was like yeah man I just I spent too
much time boozing like I could because I
could drink a Russian under the table
with a Bach was I drink so much smokes a
lot too he said that yeah he's like I
drank wait I [ __ ] up like it so they
divorced yeah I was that well I though
he's got his own drinking he like it was
a huge drink prominent goes once we got
separated I slept on my I don't know if
I believe this because he's richest but
he said he slept on his uh best friends
for for six weeks he couldn't function
yeah but his best friends it's probably
the king of Thailand is also talked
about every form
I have to sleep on the floor what a
tomato Nathan chances it's all your nuts
overnight informative naked job Megan
Jen I slept on your kids and asked if
you instill a flora sea of tits and ass
it was relevant you know for him to come
out and be like that it's all me man I
know I [ __ ] up I'm addicted to alcohol
man I just drank myself and Abel poor
guy he like you can like him marijuana a
little bit yeah I feel good yeah he
likes his cigarette slices marijuana
what I'm always amazed at is when I
spent a little bit of time whenever you
meet some big people or you see them in
a group I'm amazed how hard they booze
and drink and yeah who's in smoke like
yes I'm always like damn everybody here
smokes and drinks I yeah you know you
know what I'm always in drugs
I'm always when I see when I meet a pro
fighter or like around for like tyron
woodley had a thing in this when they
eat bad and I'm surprised lately but
yeah I'm super surprisingly Bamie with
the dessert table twice at lunch and
come on Mike what are you doing man
Giant Killer
still looks like a Greek guy yells yeah
boy he was in canonized anyways do when
I'm not training I take a mental and
physical break a friend but he's body is
like a Greek guy why didn't you see oh
man I agree without explaining himself
but whenever actually I always imagine
them being super disciplined in their
diet in a way they train all this what
wouldn't he's been a wrestler forever so
he's had to worry about losing sucking
waist since probably seven you know but
really but you're giving eat like normal
people it doesn't rat always been
arrested us whole life if you're gonna
eat you know like a normal person like
when you're not in pain actually when
you're not so when you were in camp did
you eat Bob's a heavy weight but evil
eyes up to me it's like if I cheated I
was in camp I felt I could affect my
fights are super strict even when you're
now you even go down fall where my my
coach in Denver Lauren land a yeah dude
you have got to start eating like I need
calories bring me pizza is like you have
to get calories right bring me whatever
I would eat right I just I was like
chicken broccoli right he's like what
you're not you're a heavy weight man
yeah I don't give a [ __ ] how you look we
need calories right so I DP'd so you'd
bring me pizzas but if he wasn't around
I'd eat super strict right I always
wanted to by drinking I know you don't
drink you don't really drink dude I was
wondering about drinking too what do you
mean like
the fighters that drink like how do they
do it when they don't do it you know I
mean last John Jones well they even get
physilog to come be everybody you ever
notice it when you were training did you
ever notice that any like a food that
you would eat or like drinking was there
anything that would affect your
performance the next day or I didn't
dream telling you are a really well yeah
I don't drink you know that'd be that'd
be the hardest but I was I was uh I was
jealous of guys in football and fighting
who could drink and then come the next
day and still perform well right and
mentally didn't they didn't give a [ __ ]
all right
they'd have three hours of sleep Mike
what's up and you should do work I just
never died I did you see the thirty four
thirty on the Chicago Bulls the 85 Bears
85 Bears know how my Jim Vick me I'm a
fixer people someone I think it might
been barstool sports and went this I
want my quarterback in this Jim McMahon
first day of walk in the Chicago Bears
training camp and he has a huge cooler
and his Bud Light on the top and he has
a backwards hat I was really going to
check in for a first aid training camp
and if you McMahon put just headed to
training camp and it's just like all
this bear like back in the day he was a
crazy on that it during the season
not just on Tonga sometimes I got bad
CTE I wonder if him didn't hit other
than alcohol yeah it's a party I'm
jealous those guys though they could end
and still perform
there's actors like that there's
conveniens like that the other can mean
to get high as [ __ ] and then go on stage
and I just never do that I couldn't do
it I cannot do that
there's athletes who can stay up all
night in the next mortgage I think
alcohol and weed these things affect
people differently depending on your
body chemistry it's just like medicine
some medicines you know work with some
people some don't have you always
measuring I just I don't have the
Constitution for it so so blow weed any
of that stuff for real like I can't I'm
the only guy you know that can do three
lines and stop you know people that do
it do all the cocaine yeah I [ __ ] I
can do I'm not a coke guy but I mean in
the times I've done it I'll do two three
lines and be like yeah I'm tossing what
was I don't like it you're not I wasn't
you gotta drink like whiskey like you
like yeah
yeah you got a drink yeah like you're a
man's man like everything well you take
your birthday party Oh what is this
birthday if you drink there's actually
cake your brother you know he's all whoa
and [ __ ] the fling goes seals Wow oh
I was laughing no no we're good right
the wax of the candle yeah close my eye
because I because I hit it and it was
wet and it closed my eye and it stayed
on and until the next day I couldn't
open my eye I woke up correctly so
waxing the candle close my eye on my
would have all its friends please
whoo you're like my sister
I like one because that's like when I
had a sunroom and a shitty Acuras in my
bed that was with my girl and she I came
when I got really excited and I was like
yeah Wow and I went to shoot my hand out
of the [ __ ] laughs and I forgot how I
liked that I I hurt my hand like hurt it
was actually damaged for a three-wheel
and do my girls laughing sorry right oh
my gosh oh my gosh I love when people
[ __ ] w my girl's mom had a party and
there's just a giant beasts milk you
know like she's making sure like
everything's were here is perfect she
picked it out that way oh [ __ ]
she is so good she does it realize that
the glass door is shut she thinks is
open it was like they're like mock Maria
you look beautiful tonight thank God you
look so damn good
she's like thank you mamacita but Wiress
so hard where she goes thank you mommy
keep doing and [ __ ] sausage and she
I've never seen throwing sombras and now
Joe Sam is very polite like oh my god
you're right I go oh [ __ ] I can't stop
laughing man I'm really done I think
that stuff makes me laugh the hard or
anything like that
kids might fool the Japs my father going
to this yellow flower that killed me I
don't know I love [ __ ] I love it
it's like in love it god that reminded
me of something I was going to try to
tell you about and I forgot what the
[ __ ] the story was exactly like that
though once the next time you leave was
July for the expand the expanse got the
expanses of show if you guys don't watch
it it's on I mean it's on Syfy Amazon
Netflix Internet is on your third season
when our third season did like a cult
following - yeah this season did really
really well like the expanse and hit me
up on pillars got a blast on there's a
frame for top five oh my god Pete it's
sci-fi nerd' every day but you know it's
funny as the expanse more than anything
that I've ever been a part of is the
fans are so smart and it's so on and in
the sense I answer yet because it yes I
am so we did this a science panel at
Caltech and there were a thousand
it was a conscious everything here at
Cal Tech whoa kids whoo it was a lot of
fun but it yeah it is whoa kids whoa
whoa that's right instead of beer head
like a happy gilmore [ __ ] hole in one
man's it's a good I like banging dudes
with but when I meet them and they start
talking about the science of the show
I'm like this way with money like that
very cool man just literally hell my
lines I don't know how to [ __ ] to marry
Peyton I'm a fan of sci-fi though like I
was always a family lately literally
here come now what did you what branch
somehow I was in I was aviation
firefighter I worked on the flight deck
I was in the Navy
no [ __ ] were you an aviation fighter for
fire yeah I don't hear about it I was
running what I know I worked for the I
worked for the me we worked on our Gunny
a lot of times because it was a
amphibious carrier so it was we had a
captain and we had a you're the
bell-bottoms in that little hat it that
was phased out like I had a year of that
and that crates out that that outfit
phased out but I like that outfit I
wanted to go but we worked you know
definitely what we worked in we never
wear that when you were going to slide
that you wear jerseys and like camo
pants right and that dangerous to is not
that that wire that can yeah great game
plan and it's uh
it's you know it's a very very dangerous
drought but it's extremely dangerous for
people that zone out like I do like I am
a daydreamer man like I cannot pay
attention and so the fact that I
survived for years being on the flight
because this one place has to be a
winner people there's like the line
right because the the reason why so
dangerous those f16 jets land right in
the chord yeah and if your digital yeah
heads off cuz we have your leg like they
show us that but see I was on an
amphibious carry so we didn't have the
catapult like like the dementia but was
dangerous for us was Harriers areas are
extremely faint you YouTube like being
sucked in the engine of a Harrier you
have to see this and I'll show you like
the job is but the Harriers engine was
so powerful if you walk in five feet in
front of Harrier it sucks you into their
engine who does you have to mean some
people survive some people died and then
when they turn it on you the Jets in the
back will blow you up like why is it
yeah is I just sucked and watch this and
I I think is that yeah this in your
credit so this is what I did it's what I
little shitty way to go yeah you can
imagine if you're a parent others so
this is what we everybody starts off
chocking and chained the plane just what
you start off doing trying to training
yeah and so when you're up he stood up
right now it'll suck them into the
engine so you have to know where the
suck zone is and you're doing this but
what why is it that hair cut open oh
dude that's amazing
this little Jam that's a bullet with a
[ __ ] are they gonna build up the
system
Katie get out of the [ __ ]
oh my god it sucked him right in did you
see it it's like a crash dummy sit like
oh it's like I just stand now what
what's in that engine
nothing I don't know that others that's
the so you get your face we may want to
engineer your head taken off what happen
but happen with with I think it was this
guy what happens sometimes it it sucks
your cranial off so it sucks you're so
fast that it suckers Crangle off the
question
jammed it and and fogged it out before
before he hit it for Christ and not a
good way to do it
there's strop to try to help you know
we're about out and go back home I feel
when all the choices but there'd be
thought about ct2 in our builders every
towns I just be daydreaming mid-flight
dick
I feel like I don't know if that's a win
but nah that did what any person a big
softy hey bro hey let's always say the
girls down wasn't the subs oh I'm like a
Harrier jet [ __ ] yeah you just
entered the areas word that's so
dangerous like they had the most so
[ __ ] so most fires we had on the
flight deck were Harris era decision
some [ __ ] I never got to thank God I
don't know how I will tell room that
from now on
welcome to sons its leg so that's a
great show so welcome no Saiyans you
sucked right in there I honestly don't
know because I I get absent-minded like
I honestly don't know how I survived
four years on the flight deck because I
do
I've heard people like there's times
where just like I'm hearing some playing
a page I mean what time I look at my his
so I get my hand out daydreaming and I
hear it's like Saint Wordsworth and I
look around and I'm in the middle of
like with a plant like a dog [ __ ] I just
like said am i oh [ __ ] dude was it a
good experience so those four years of
military yeah I had a great experience
and mainly the great experiences the
people that you work with like the
people you don't like you become I still
talk to him on the phone all the time we
become like family
sure and and so close to him but it was
it was a great experience for me are
there women on the on the boat there was
a sucked on the highway not the doctor
not my son when I was on the Essex for
two years first and there was no women
on the book how long would you be on a
boat how long had a stretch would you be
on a boat the longest well you do I did
to West Pacific tours and so that's six
months six months six months just the
fell six months on a boat just to file
is like in the morning see but you're
porting you're going in how often
important what depends I mean so the
first time
first no yes yup flowers you [ __ ]
yourself the animals got two hours ago
kids go get herpes immediately that's
why it's what I get by rotation I mean
when you go on to Thailand
you're so hungry but everywhere so here
18 years old 19 years old hundred
dollars in your pocket
that lady boys here horses yeah now you
get a couple second close enough you
cook yeah man so you guys pulling the
point you're just like a bunch of uh
horndog yeah man just just yeah I mean
it was you get drunk and eat yeah but
there was a time when we were in the
Gulf for three months my first tour so
you know you're gone for six months but
you pulling for it probably once or
twice a week and then that's fine I you
know relieve some pressure yeah but
literally yeah but I there was a time we
were in the Gulf or three months trade
anchors it wasn't like we were cruising
around we were just sitting there for
three months in the Gulf just only nuts
oh my god it was it was correcting the
bunkers like you said you bet on the
bunkers yeah I mean it you couldn't you
couldn't do anything you work all day
all you did was work out you work all
day you work out you get swole eat bro
good I'll show you actually show you
pictures when those yeah man city yeah
no hey I know you have big gay fantasies
but it wasn't a bunch of guys like guys
what are we doing we worked out with
work books we shaved our chests food
highlighted our hair well guess nothing
else do but common each other
I do wish you how many forms of the
dangerous Sutton's oh man I know I'm big
guys but if you guys hold me down and
have your way with me I'm gonna be so
mad that's one of my prison-house blue
screws yeah I guess something new got it
if you saw this Tommy the other one drop
some bombs in my mouth yeah are you
flexible I don't know about to find out
yeah let's see if this kid can do the
splits with his tummy on the play now
it's don't-ask don't-tell right like if
there's no no that was what it was now
now it's now you'd be what everyone hate
yeah you be gay what it was there run
you can come out with it yeah yeah now
you guys couple up yeah I guess I don't
know how that works I'm when I went to
back then it was something like if the
guy was raging gay what
I was in it was Don't Ask Don't Tell and
uh and I didn't know of any you know I
didn't know of I'm sure that's you know
I'm sure that did you uh did you ever
get seasick out there I did once we went
we caught telling a typhoon one time and
that death shook me up man that was nice
why is the military though for you you
got out of high school and you're just
kind of oh I I wanted because I wanted
to go to school and I felt like in and I
didn't want to go right away but it just
it made sense to me I come from my dad
was in military his dad was in the
military was one way for me to get out
of the town that I grew up in and it was
also you know I wanted to have that
experience I wanted to travel I wanted
to experience what that was like and and
then also they you know they paid for my
school when I got out so that was really
good but I mean it was one valuable
experience in my life it was really it
was the most meaningful thing that I'm
you know you're reading the actor when
you were going through the military I
did I knew I was going to I knew eyes I
knew I wanted to tell so I want to be a
storyteller I wanted to I didn't know
and what in Carnation it was going to be
and I I wrote a play when I was in
school
and like and we perform and everything
so that's kind of like what I thought
that I was going to do they still they
may know one things that I like about
you is that you're you read a lot and
I've read I think oh three books you've
given to me that I really enjoyed but
you um
you're you have an active intellectual
life and that's very rare in LA like you
and I have bonded on that I mean yeah
absolutely you know yeah she goes a so
what my question into his habit too and
he goes these are all the books I'm
reading and he has this whole there's
the thing and I was like this is amazing
why are you not wearing pants and then
an address a different story was all
about books we read oh yeah right why
you didn't go to learn events how long
do we I don't have to get going I don't
have a good I got pretty read of my time
I just finished Hamilton the the
Alexander Hamilton and that and it was
because I actually went to I actually
went to his museum and nevis and it's
all like where he grew up and like
here's a long how why Hamilton is so
important it's important well he was
definitely the most prolific of the
founding fathers you know nobody had the
amount of work ethic that he had but he
was the most politically inquiry
act of the founding father he didn't
give a [ __ ] died for it and died for ya
and and the so in a sense like I think
you know with the exception of Benjamin
Franklin I think he did more to develop
this country than all of the founding
that that is that is what historians
yeah concurrent right and then fought a
duel with Aaron Burr who was so I was
going to handle the secretary of the
Treasury I believe Aaron Burr was do you
remember Aaron Burr at that time we ran
for president yeah and he was yeah he
ran for president and they fought a duel
where they recycle what happened was
when I was so held to those Thomas
always his son Thomas Jefferson in
Hamilton
hate each other they were at odd and but
the only person that that that Hamilton
hated more I don't even know he hated
him but he disrespected more was Aaron
Burr so when have Jefferson was running
against Aaron Burr and all of a sudden
Hamilton went in favor for Jefferson do
I put the [ __ ] you guys hate each other
for years and now you're going for and
Aaron's like dude I cannot in Hamilton
as always every time Aaron wrote rose up
Hamilton was SWAT him down so then
Hammett Burr was like okay well at least
I get to be vice president and be and
she was like nah so that was the first
Jefferson that was the first year that
the the runner-up didn't get to become
vice president and so they had issued
Burroughs like you know what [ __ ] you
and within that we're going to but you
know in my life he did and then it
killed him and that really really ruin
his life Here I am
yeah it's an amazing story man about how
and one of the most amazing things about
the founding of this country was that
after the Revolutionary War in almost
every example in history when there's a
revolution and it was kind of revised
revolution were for their independence a
civil war almost always breaks out
because factions compete for for you
know
Germany and in this case that was not
the case the election of 1800 was the
nastiest [ __ ] thing in the world but
they just refused to go to want arms
over it right anyway I believe it is so
close to the the other revolution the
revolution they 881 fought or of yeah
acqua see right well anyway I'm gonna be
Hamilton's well done do it guys oh
here's some code avenge 10 yeah I got a
current events with live chat um yeah
you didn't do any song agree oh really
I don't know why the music guide is Bob
doing it really yeah but I'm gonna find
it back I'll get it back I just just
kind of died and me you stopped doing it
I put sound [ __ ] great I saw you on
Instagram doing that up there with the
band yeah very for us to me
yeah I'm talented woody got still Jen
hashtag still got it hashtag better than
ever hashtag 50 alright first one is the
flight from Japan to LA I want to see
some rent some guy just randomly went up
to another guy I was sitting down and
just attacked him just randomly randomly
there's no reason nobody's just so
frustrated like [ __ ] of Abita there's
gotta be a reason
so I'll show you the footage of a little
bit about Dan
ah the guy in that horrible metal wire
he yeah he painted I
[Music]
so he's cussing at him he's trying to
crawl at him really bad punching
terrible punch your elbows in no and
then anyways he comes back after a while
and does it again didn't scream but
what's all this video which guy did this
guy did again are the guy in the red
shirt randomly attack the guy with a
black shirt but here's what's
interesting what's going through your
head there because if you full-on defend
yourself in the back you're mine you
like when this plane lands I'm going to
jail because if dude there's no
questions at zero tolerance on planes so
if he's going to jail even if you defend
know somebody that actually say and
initially you're going to gesture like
but I'm saying it in because there's
such zero it's so extreme with violence
and she on a plane yeah in my mind
that's why BJJ so valuable because you
just choke that guy out and I can be
tough because how would you do it
I just [ __ ] grab him over thing and
choke him over the he just said and done
that or even you can even do a
guillotine like pulling long exactly er
I mean if he came come back what his
weird [ __ ] up is he's staying in the
bed he can be wrecked come to that right
you need to get out a little cuz the guy
like he can grab the bag the guys can
grab the back of his neck
oh and then when he comes
Aaron see now decent job where is the
bouncy if you grab there any goose
jumping on that the woman is like please
yeah where is all the dudes why are they
just watching you because they're
probably I'm not going to jail yeah
where they go I mean if you what would
you do a few I for sure stand up and
stop like I would too yes yeah I
wouldn't sit there one Hanson yeah it's
weird to me how people are such [ __ ]
yeah
JD's laughing oh [ __ ] J be like Chuck I
chased notic from the participating
citizen you would have to stop it well
I'll have to do [ __ ] there's just
naturally just like what are you doing
it sit there would you use if they if
they actually were talking [ __ ] John had
beef and so I find them that's on them
but the guys innocently just sitting
there yet it looks so like it was
something from before right TV
know-it-all to say completely random but
the guy that was the victim I got
attacked he was saying that he they're
both from the military he found out that
the other guy was from the military too
he feels as though that was like a
post-traumatic stress thing oh no
something like he just PTSD just hit him
and just randomly attack this guy that's
what so that's the guy the victims you
got a defend yourself time yeah did you
see the one on the subway where the guy
was doing that and do come up behind him
he's choked him about knocking him out
and just put his foot on his chest yeah
way too they were very calm and I'll she
got you all right this one a 12 year old
girl was told to leave a chess
tournament because her dress was too
seductive and this is her actual dress
that's the [ __ ] dress and she's a 12
year old girl yes Malaysia killed in the
lake odd man address the tournament
director told her she had to leave and
then so her coach
complained obviously and then they said
the only way she can come back as if she
went went to buy slacks
yeah so they stalled the tournament but
then the next day the only store that
opened would be at 9 o'clock not enough
time to make the tournament if she
misses she miss Lamor son sir she's
wearing horizontal stripes with vertical
stripe oh right yeah Yemen I would let
her compete just off that alone I
understand that's legit but I mean when
you're doing a fashion faux pas it's
fine but I guess you can't show her that
I'd rather get you much yeah cause yes
shows her need to get her fellow 12 year
olds to horny
that's not that's what he was saying
yeah ignorant real memories alive and
well in them in the world everybody but
if you're 12 you're gonna get money
regardless no matter what oh yeah you're
12 you know your boys made a tragedy I
was I got so embarrassed I did did this
round table thing for my other podcast
mixed mental arts and I had these smart
and women around we were going to talk
about sexism and I open up with
basically and they're like these Harvard
and Columbia educated you know writers
and and I go you know I got to say as a
white guy and it's a white male I'm
really finding it unsafe to just express
myself and I just tell you like I was
like yeah I go I just think it's like
it's like I can't be myself I have to
censor myself I'm afraid too many my
criticize me I feel like you know the
world is like you know looking at me as
this toxic person or that I might do
something wrong and get criticized and
the women go wow wait so you have to
censor yourself and you have to be aware
of your behavior I've never I want that
like I've never had some egos Latos
Bears I don't as like oh my god what's
it like I have to send yourself oh my
god you have to sit differently when
you're in a dress what's it like and I
was like god dammit why the [ __ ] so
embarrassed right with money is that
that statement like you make trying to
make a point shows how detached from my
right you know like she was like that's
why we're me yeah yeah that was a
classic way to start because I was like
oh yeah I guess you guys have had to
deal with that forever right wherever
yeah that's the guy you use your
everyday existence and just now you get
married off yeah it's property like a
rape was considered up until recently
rape even I don't mean in this country
but well actually yes even in this
country rape on a woman was the man was
the one who would be given sort of
compensation because it was a violation
of his property so it was never a
woman's not out in this court
nonetheless well in up in this country I
believe those laws in the 30s 20s I
think certainly in the 1880 we live in a
third no rape rape was something that
one Hannah but rape was considered a
crime against the man because that was
his property right and that's certainly
the case in most countries and was for a
long time because a woman was considered
part of your property find out what rape
law is like in in this country I think
in the 1800s that was considered still a
crime against a man and I'm Cossack
Warthog would write a paper it's
significant because the idea that rape
is a crime against a woman and her
serenity and her person is actually a
very new concept not only in most of the
world but also in the Western world that
is a new concept that I knew it
certainly is it certainly is new it's
not something that was like in the 20s
or the by the way in the 20th of a woman
got raped believe me the first thing
asked was what did she do to deserve it
what was she doing to agitate a man and
not only and I'm sorry it goes up into
the 50s when women in the 50s were raped
whose all good the rape girls when women
not someone's that someone I'm saying
legally when women were raped in the 50s
good luck prosecuting that without a lot
of witnesses because it was your word
against hers and most importantly she
was put up on the stand and she was
basically said what were you wearing
what were you doing did you bring him
into your by the way when you brought a
man into your room at night that was you
were done and if you raped you hey man
you were asking for it that is a very so
so believe me this this is very new
these ideas so what was some of the what
were some of the main things that you
learned working with you so Todd but
during the pot mainly that I was blind
to recompile a victim out all those
people why don't I I don't know how you
open it by its McFaul
victims right now he goes guys I'd like
to start like it's like it was surprise
real big eye hot so victimized I can't
be myself they're like put your--let's
from men all the time you hear this
tremendous with who do you know that
we're being branded the oppressors and
with toxic guy I'd say should a lot of
that movement you know John yeah no I
yes you do and we we all have friends
that basically think that there's a war
on boys a war on men that's whether they
have like men's support groups of course
I don't have any friends in the
zero hey girlfriends are like I'm in a
man's no I'm talking about what I'm
saying is that there's there is
especially in academia in the workplace
there is a lot of that talk that that is
a fact that is the news where men and
their automotives called for some of it
makes sense
true a lot of it makes sense right the
Bill O'Reilly stuff you're with the Bill
O'Reilly stuff I don't know always
chosen yeah yeah yeah you know someone
makes a you know a how women a treat and
stuff like that yeah man it's also
subtle too you know that one of the
things we were talking about they were
talking about how sexual harassment they
were talking about like this [ __ ] you
deal with it you don't realize the woman
so you may are you may like go in an
interview for a job right if the guy
like the guy could easily ask you out
after the interview and if he asked you
out in the interview and you say no or
the guy makes advances okay let's just
think about this he's your boss you're
working as a woman you have a dream to
fulfill and the dude is your boss and he
kind of you guys are working together
and he likes you and he makes an advance
me story says we want to go hiking
whatever and you say you're not into
them and you say no they I talk to these
women about this and you say you kind of
do whatever you do you can't do it
there's no way to prove that that guy
some dudes are gonna be like no problem
but there's some dudes they're going to
hold that against you and you are going
and your job is going to suffer from
it's hard to prove right they have to be
with that [ __ ] all and that the problem
is is insidious you know because how do
you suddenly improve because you can
just subtly start parting ways and you
can't prove so woman right it's they all
died I don't groans I won't say the
company she applied for the job and then
he responded back and was like hey we
should go out stuff like that and she's
like I'm good I have a boyfriend
and she goes but keep me posted out the
job though not by weeks went by and
she's like what's up he's like sorry
give someone else she was so qualified
and she's a good person Stockman and we
I know who what you're talking to who
and we both know that guy he was a piece
of [ __ ] what else we got chin
all right surfer in Scotland I believe
of Scotland he was missing at sea for 32
what and finally got rescued Wow he
stayed on his board on his board I think
was like 13 miles out into the ocean and
you're surfing got taken by the yeah
ripped out of the car it was a magnum
p.i have sorry about that
no super just yeah he got caught out in
it what they found was a helicopter or
his family knew who's missing family
knew is missing so no no but it was
super cold what saved them was his
neoprene wetsuit ale and staying on his
board of course already 35 hours how
cersei are you by the way think about
that know what goes through your head
that you're gonna die of thirst because
you know anything about what he's just
chillin on his surfboard right yeah
sitting there going back and forth
choppy cold weather legs so that's good
news
wait so through say toddler how about
was it three days Englewood I was three
days 21 days ah I'm sorry three days in
water 21 days without food yeah it
depends though about water you can drop
in 12 otherwise forty days right in the
desert 45:41 food in Jarrettsville yeah
21 days they say that's the ex would
like I'm making afraid if they don't
have one in three days if they don't
find water right I usually get them out
of give them water right the first name
shows 21 days
starvation else that was Gandhi 21 days
riding with 21 days yeah who's gonna
tell her that famous quote remember that
famous scene in that movie and he's it's
clear that he really said that when I
guy was eat I'm going to hell eat I
killed
I killed a Muslim boy he was a Hindu -
yet and then he said I think it was out
of hand when he said I took out
five-year-old Muslim boy and bashed his
brains against the whole time and then
Gandhi said I know a way out he said
find an orphan and five-year-old orphan
has lost his parents and raised him but
raised him as a Muslim three days long
even though it's really powerful
three days without water 20 same article
mothers up yeah what does she got
brother
because there's some people do those
fasting like religious fasting they go I
mean [ __ ] insane a long time anyways
what's the longest you've ever did you
ever have you've had miss Bessie I pass
all the time
what's longest ah usually 18 hours but
I'll do when I was given four metamoris
I do 24 hours right did you uh have you
ever tried intermittent fasting mmm well
so that that worked out that worked
really well for me
I saw some studies on Good Morning
America where they say that the
intermittent fasting the the fact that
fine science has been behind it really I
hear different things but you know
everything I've read it on it said it
but eat but I just had like it
illegitimate Lee worked for me yeah I
liked it that I was doing a job and
there's a certain amount that I had to
losing a certain amount of time and I
didn't know and that's the only thing I
did and not eating it we did it yeah
yeah yes I'm sorry I didn't want to tell
me that don't eat lose weight period
what else get Jim all right there's a
youtube star family is the dude and his
step wife and they would post prank
videos all the time of their kids and
they would do like messed up things to
make the kids cry so they eventually
lost the custody of to to their children
so that's the biological father they had
five kids and they will continue to
prank two of the kids and I saw one of
the pranks because they deleted all the
videos or they [ __ ] up they [ __ ] up
that they will so they would they would
have them on YouTube and prank them
frankly they would cry and they would
have a humongous audience like millions
and not only you guys give it to million
online users of this your dumb for doing
that one of these videos was them
pretending to put like fake ink on the
children's floor and then throwing like
a bunch of cards out and blaming the
kids for it they would yell it after you
how dare you do this the kids are just
crying my god [ __ ] you and then later on
they were just kidding but the kids are
damaged that's hell yeah you did being
raised like that that's rude that also
[ __ ] you to people that watch that bull
yeah there what's wrong with people
two million one hundred seventy one
thousand two hundred and six pounds yeah
bunch of moral what the [ __ ] is wrong
with people
here's the video I would hold up I don't
want to watch it I don't want to watch
them making I don't want to go back and
keep yeah what a piece of [ __ ] that's
what happens that day you know we're all
the
I say I cannot you know was angry I
can't like it angers me you know hot
what else you got gin I got one more
just this one
and that's beer FBI translator ended up
marrying someone she spied on who is
part of the ISI so high state absolutely
sweet at the movie yeah
how surprising all of a sudden she
realizes he's a terrorist but he's a
human being and he's doing it for the
ideology he was a rapper in Germany too
for the law then he became one of the
most like one of the best recruiters for
Isis because looking he's got a
cauliflower and damn look at that it
says uh saying she was gonna fly to
Germany to see her family green instead
flew to Turkey and from there travel to
Syria enjoy that life yeah enjoy that
we've got big almond ice very
penetrating plaintiff fat dick she's
probably watching what I like lose that
Isis dick we want to 504 so shut ur
mouth so salivating and chimp they see
no I love this guy I know he's really
mean I know he totally advocates
violence constantly so that's how you
know you got something you got something
special if you could be a terrorist
recruiter for ice women like Dana is
just doing danger you know [ __ ] more
yeah but she's a more Isis yeah did you
know there's danger then there's like
but they have done the studies on one on
how they like a bad boy yeah yeah
but there's a difference between there's
no string like in a bad boy liking here
whether you did you think it ate sense
exactly right oh yeah hurts there's a
lot of members to DOJ deck its yes it
was phenomenal it was incredible time of
the one that won the yeah that one but I
didn't see the documentary I saw the
mini Co you have to watch that ah you
saw the thirty four thirty because there
was a multiple parts yeah I did not it's
funny about that is one of the best that
I've ever seen one all those awards it
kind of it kind of paralleled OJ's
experience with football and with it
with his trial with race relations in LA
and the police it's phenomenal but the
third act of the documentary is his
spiral into darkness when he's living in
Miami like after the trial and he's
going on
in vacant and he says in the videos he's
making like rap videos he says in videos
he was just interesting because I get
more women now than I did before and
it's just it's such a dark revelation of
way yeah the who is morally we don't
like all these drugs and he'd like you
to bless what was saying like he was
like I've never got so many women like I
mean three for a night like that even
when I was OJ playing football and I
didn't get this month now and he's a
killer now now you're a killer looking
at this chart look at it you can do you
know those letters I and dick yeah so so
they did these studies about how danger
a dangerous man taps into a lot of cases
these coordinates to neuroscientist it
taps into the same I guess neural area
of the brain that sexual the you know
excitement does I don't know man it's
pretty wild
I'm glad I don't know it makes sense
that women would evolve too much to it
no no no no it's absent your is no log
good read about it in that billion
wicked thoughts actually where they
scared women where they would like how
you're going to I saw the study and
they'd correlated go into the movie like
a scary movie releases the same
endorphins that like sexual route yeah
yeah but date they also they also think
it some of them make sense because
aggression so the yanomamö in in Brazil
they what was really kind of like all
the ants anthropology and they were
[ __ ] crucified for the came back and
they went you know what the warriors in
this group of people that have had no
contact with Western civilization
because this was when aggression has to
be learned and you know there's there's
no such thing as natural aggression well
they were like well the men that came
back with the most heads and had the
most decoration they would decorate
their get daggers and their skirts
basically without a building a luck zone
they got they were in Osaka hey God
level these women of the the fireside
women you know women Homer were drawn
that why because well probably
aggression and a guy who can keep you
safe and [ __ ] everybody up is a guy you
want to breed with and that because that
longest gene but that's also yeah so
yeah I mean you know you can say we want
but to do to over and over that's that
seems to be yeah but there's a
difference with this like the oj thing
that's well there that's a little ring
yeah that's love notes you know I'm
saying like yeah oh yeah who married uh
Charles Manson just coming yeah Richard
Ramirez there's somebody in who is the
Ted Bundy Butthead by an Ted Bundy was
yes women more I got fan mail
oh it's a heart all of them do so you
say oh now that these so I draw pictures
or they can't benefit from any of that
stuff anymore because we get such a fan
base yeah who draws things in prison and
then sell it that's how those finances
first movie
Todd's dogs got John Wayne Gacy to make
a poster he was doing a documentary on a
guy named GG Allin GG Allin with John
Wayne Gacy lover in prison GG Allin was
a performance artist a crazy man he used
to bite the heads off a rats and all the
[ __ ] in the Lower East Side and for real
he would do crazy [ __ ] and I was like
I'm gonna do a documentary on this guy
so I need more money
yep and he so he found out that he was
in jail John Wayne Gacy so Todd called
John Wayne Gacy got in touch with a
modem a letter John Wayne Gacy called
him with a collect call and Todd had to
fill out a questionnaire like John Wayne
Gacy sent him get to fill out this
questionnaire yeah and then he said look
I want you to make a poster I want you
to draw his a really good draftsman
bring it up you can probably see it it's
called hated this is drawing up hated
bring up things composer for hated and
he brought this so he said
draw a poster of of GG Allin Todd but
this house smart Todd as Todd [ __ ]
drew it up and he the drama gets you to
up Todd make posters of it and [ __ ] a
solders of benefit and Brooklyn so got
an ad they took out an ad and and
basically he's in better artwork he sold
all those and had him sign see houses
jay-z he sold a thousand of them and he
stole them for a thousand dollars each
or no no I'm sorry it was like a hundred
and fifty or something and the kid do
that anymore he raised some 100 on for
me yesterday raised $100,000 movies you
make over he made this amazing
documentary called hated when GG Allin
end up killing himself while they were
making the job
they see dark [ __ ] doesn't yeah well I
can't they found 34 boys in his uh oh
look at that look at that he was a clown
for children that's why I'm so we could
hug them yeah I'm reading it now
anything up ooh yes sir no new movies
coming on you know and that's why that's
why I started reading it cuz in the
media before know you're in there I know
I I saw the original movie and I've read
most of Kings Kings but in shining read
what's I read The Shining yes
anything else Jim that's it Oh boom did
you got another drop of knowledge I had
a knowledge yeah I had a dropping
knowledge I mean really quickly I just
want to get your take on this really
quickly so there's this pilot program
that some of these academics were
talking about which was they want to
think about the government shaming
people into paying their taxes so you
take the top 500 people who are the most
delinquent who a millions of dollars and
actually posting their names and stuff
what do you guys think of that idea to
put post B to shame them into paying
their tax that's stupid I don't think
it's a good idea
I don't either I don't think I was
having this argument with thee I don't
think that the government should operate
on that level I agree you know in terms
of getting into business of shaming
people or manipulating in that way well
just so you know there's there's a there
seems to be a body of a movement where
that people are pushing for that and
it's in its in its and I don't think the
government should stoop to that level
out government all because if the
government what else are you gonna do
right yes oh you're you're an adulterer
let's shame you that way well who's the
government to post your [ __ ] to take
your anonymity and put it up the web it
opens up bad you're right that is no
debt is a wrong rabbit hole to go down
that is a tricky road and it's important
to know that because there's a lot of
movement there you'll always have
subsets the population academics smart
people make good arguments for this that
will push this and I'll say dude they
owe money we can use that money for this
we can use that money for that their
academics would live a [ __ ] boring
lives of course they don't care if it
was Fatima well there's an ideology
there too which is like let's let's put
a lot of trust in this big central
government better yeah I agree better
but I'm getting nervous is the fact that
you people can't go speak at
universities like different ideologies
different even though there's just
deplorable few people that I can't stand
they can't the rioting in the streets
like we had at Berkeley or what happened
charles murray who wrote a bell carbon
yeah great podcast with sam harris he
did a great idea controversial stuff and
that wasn't allowed to speak yeah in
fact the professor that brought him
there got her next year to go to
hospitals yes you get assault is right
yeah that's the that's the there are two
organizations one is the anti a fema or
whatever anti-fascist movement and
another movement they just [ __ ] yo
curses but it also goes against what the
free speech guys you know it's all
either you have to punch somebody could
somebody comes in there with an idea
then you're not very confident your own
ideas is that me we don't have enough
you don't have an idea nobody's you'll
have a good always the way you may be a
bad idea is with a better idea yeah and
people like that are just not very smart
right and then this is his all doesn't
lash out community oh you're saying I
don't like I'm going to punch yeah and
Bill Moore system was really funny
because he in on his show because I
guess Howard Dean said hate speech is
not defended under the free speech that
how we're gonna do it would and Bill
Maher goes [ __ ] yes it is yes it is
that's what it's about Dean is a [ __ ]
joke Howard Dean is a is a is a [ __ ]
[ __ ] he [ __ ] kiyohara yeah he is he's
just like [ __ ] hours again of course
Howard Dean would to say that he's a
lightweight
I'm sorry I don't like that guy we can
they find you but lobster your
experience on sci-fi in his language all
I see is you comes out in October
who and the escape plan comes out I
don't know when that comes out but yeah
we start back shooting this expanding
season three in July so yeah well glad
we finally got Charlie yeah you know I
want to give them a go it's I'm excited
to tell you I've been I've known you
guys for a while now so decided come to
the show but it's interesting because of
the fighter and the kid atmosphere
reminds me a lot of Fight Club
you know because remember when like
Tyler Durden would show up I right and
people would not and they would kind of
know but when I go places with Brendan
like we went to like we if we go to a
restaurant or some you just to just kind
of get Brendan a little nod and you know
in the end people that were as helping
Brendan with movies house and the movers
that he had their site they're all
firing the kid bands they give them a
little not good lot of like it's cool
like underground army yeah it is like
legitimacy it's like a go to hell in
there all right we had recognized all
times yeah I I like walking around with
Brenda because I just by proxy people
though are use boxing coach Selena they
asked me that to go are you yours boxing
coach right and I went at that pause and
I went yeah I'm sure as I am yeah I knew
it I love having you on that date they
have have I don't see you enough you're
awesome alright guys we love you ah
maybe doing some dates come see me
tomorrow
Vancouver you Fox Thursday Friday
Saturday on the comedy mix let's go
comedy makes planning calm boom fires a
kid is an Oklahoma Arkansas border it's
a little weird just looking up deep at
kake.com once you're only Colusa casino
is that gay for everything you need ever
this is the final kid we're out